all right before we talk about some
historical epic I do want to thank the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by factor factor delivers
fresh never frozen meals and a variety
of options right to your door which
makes sure you always have a meal ready
on hand which is perfect because like
I've said before grocery shopping I find
it about as enjoyable as stepping on a
drop of water while wearing socks I
don't like it I'd rather game I'd rather
game let's face it in this world we have
enough to think stress and worry about
let food not be one of life's stresses
give us tasty prepped ready in 2 minutes
meals for that binge of the 4-Hour cut
of the movie you can add or subtract the
number of weekly meals on your plan per
week or skip a week entirely if you need
to I appreciate that kind of
understanding with factors keto calorie
smart Chef Choice vegan veggie options
27 plus meals and 33 plus add-on options
they got your flavor for when that PB&J
Bender has run its course bachelor life
I hear you so click the link below go to
factor75.com and use code Johns 50 to
get yourself 50% off your first Factor
box and thank you so much to factor for
sponsoring this video I do appreciate it
and now Ridley Scott
[Music]
epic so Napoleon's the newest Ridley
Scott epic about The Life and Times of
Napoleon bonapart well I mean not his
whole life when doing a movie like this
you don't necessarily want to be like
and when he was born you know you don't
have to start there it's a rough time
for French citizens in French history
Napoleon bonapart this young ambitious
officer goes from that to leader King
Emperor guy who screwed over Edmund
Dantes and in biopic fashion we get a
look at the man be behind the curtain of
history and Wen Phoenix was great in the
role goes without say you knew he would
be funny call is that Wen Phoenix sounds
like Wen Phoenix he's playing a French
person in a biopic you can do one of
three things if you're going really
ambitious you can have it all in the
native language all in French and
subtitles or you can have the actors use
French accents to illustrate the point
or you can say [__] it all together wiin
Phoenix sounds like walking Phoenix
Russians sound British in Chernobyl
Russians also sound like this in Red
October that's essentially what this
movie does I have faith that that was
the best call maybe the actors just
aren't that great at doing French
accents maybe just sounded for but what
really makes this performance stand out
he puts the Napoleon back in Napoleon
complex you've always heard the term
Napoleon complex it's usually someone
who's short and they're trying to just
puff their chest and act tougher than
they are but if you look into it
Napoleon was just average hype but
Napoleon complex and this performance
persists him projecting his insecurities
his inability to get out of his own way
those of this is a very volatile
political situation just don't say you
are here you go you're lashing out oh
yeah Napoleon in this movie he was
quirky insecure he lashed out was a horn
dog an [__] but also a talented
military tactician that's part of what
made the battle so engaging could have
just made him this military leader no
show me the flawed man behind all that
the movie is surprisingly funny too
which you may have heard about in the
chatter of this film it is surprisingly
funny which has become a red flag
whenever I hear oh the movie is
surprisingly funny like oh God forested
humor but faith and Ridley Scott being
faith and Ridley Scott it is executed in
a much more human way in a way that just
feels like real human interactions you
know it's just humans being humans and
that does make it humorous also shows
how editing changes the context of
something couple of scenes in the
trailer they don't come across as
humorous but in the movie they were a
scene where Vanessa Kirby's hiking up
her skirt he looks down in the trailer
and almost feels like yeah that's mine
I'm going to smash that in the movie
it's much more humorous the way he's
trying to maintain eye contact and
slowly just looks down also the line in
the trailer where he's talking about
people who make mistakes and he's like I
simply never do you're like oh this
guy's going to [__] [__] up but in the
movie he's talking to a bunch of kids
and the way he's like yeah people make
mistake I I don't though I never do and
that is funny because we've seen him
make mistakes we've all known that
person or seen that kind of person talk
where you're like are you just unaware
or are you lying I want to know the
rosecolor goggles you you have on when
you look in the mirror Vanessa Kirby was
great in the film as well her character
in Napoleon had a very interesting and
complex dynamic they had a very volatile
relationship to say the least there was
some moments where I was like well yeah
that's uh I do appreciate the accuracy
of the times but Vanessa Kirby's been
having a hell of a run we know she's
great at this point but for her to stand
out in a film about Napoleon acting
opposite Wen Phoenix in a Ridley Scott
film with epic battle sequences that is
something it's it's like there are so
many elements at play to be scen
Steelers and show Steelers Wen Phoenix
is a show stealer Vanessa Kirby's a show
stealer the battle sequences themselves
show Stealers and that brings us to the
battle sequences they are out of control
great I could have gone for more of them
you know a movie like this is going to
have that text at the end that comes up
giving you the summary it talks about
Napoleon being in 61 battles I was like
I feel like I saw about three of them
but again it wants to strip that away
concentrate more on his personal life
but I really wanted more of those
battles because because they tasted that
good I mean they were really raw you got
to know that blood death destruction
even the horses bited I'll warn you
right here a horse Takes a cannonball
right to the chest in one scene but I
appreciate that kind of historical
accuracy some people might be like oh
they didn't need to show that but it's
like that it makes it feel more real but
now that we've talked about the
positives this movie definitely does
have pacing and time management issues
not only does this movie feel like it
takes place in the course of about a
couple years which is absolutely not the
case but there are pacing ises with the
movie just felt like it was dragging on
I felt like this 2hour 40-minute movie
was longer than Oppenheimer I've used
Oppenheimer as an example a few times
cuz in a world where 2023 was like 2 and
1/2 hours is the new two we've had 3 and
1/2 hour long movies 2 and 1/2 hour long
movies oppenheimer's right in the middle
so I always think did it feel longer or
shorter than Oppenheimer that said this
next part might shock you I'm really
looking forward to the 4-Hour cut in
Napoleon cuz it's all about pacing you
can have a 2hour 40-minute cut of a
movie that feels much longer than 2
hours and 40 minutes you can have a
4-Hour cut of that same movie that feels
much shorter than 4 hours can't help but
think an hour and 20 minutes of this
movie missing means there are these
important moments that Aid in the flow
that are just gone and that's why the
movie feels longer so in a world where a
4-Hour cut of this movie would be longer
but in theory could smooth the movie out
I'm definitely going to look forward to
that unless it doesn't in which case
it's just nearly an hour and a half
longer an entire romcom run time longer
like in the end Napoleon has a lot
working for it watch Phoenix Vanessa
Kirby the costumes the sets the set
design the grand scope and scale of the
entire thing and how practical it feels
epic battle sequences it truly is
cinematically immersive for better for
worse because now you're immersed in a
movie that has some pacing issues those
pacing issues aside still enjoyed myself
good time no alcohol required all right
so Napoleon have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite historical epic whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see
more
[Music]